[Música]
continuamos aquí en directo de américa
con la información económica por ello me
acompaña en el estudio mi compañero
jorge hurtado jorge bienvenido vamos a
iniciar en eeuu porque bajan baja la
inflación anual pero las alzas en los
precios continúan es un tema que pone
mucha más presión sobre toda la reserva
federal de eeuu que la próxima semana
estará elevando nuevamente los tipos de
interés para tratar de controlar esta
inflación la tasa interanual del índice
de precios del consumidor cayó dos
décimas en agosto hasta el 83 por ciento
aunque en términos mensuales los precios
subieron una décima con respecto a julio
según los datos publicados este martes
por la oficina de estadísticas laborales
la caída del 10,6 por ciento del precio
de la gasolina no fue suficiente para
compensar las subidas de otros rubros
esta es la segunda bajada continua de la
tasa interanual de inflación que en
junio alcanzó su cifra más alta en 40
años el 9,1 por ciento y en julio
retrocedió al 8,5 por ciento el gas y la
electricidad subieron mientras los
alimentos se encarecieron un 0 8% en
agosto y un 3 5% interanual su mayor
ritmo desde 1979 bueno ya está todo
inflación claramente tuvo impacto en los
mercados bursátiles la reacción fue la
mayor caída en más de dos años en la
bolsa de eeuu menos 3,9 por ciento cayó
el down jones el 4 menos 43 por ciento
louis amp y 500 y más del 5 por ciento
en el nasdaq este índice que reúne a las
grandes tecnológicas al cierre de la
jornada los operadores de renta variable
vieron cómo se borraron prácticamente la
ganancia de los últimos cuatro días en
europa las acciones cayeron un 16 por
ciento retrocediendo desde los máximos
de dos semanas alcanzados al principio
de la sesión producto del dato de
inflación de eeuu en américa latina la
bolsa de sao paulo siguió esta estela
del exterior y su índice ibovespa perdió
un 2,30 por ciento tras la publicación
del dato de inflación en eeuu bueno
jorge seguimos justamente en este país
porque allí el presidente joe biden está
intentando evitar una huelga de
transporte ferroviario que no sólo
afectaría a personas sino las cadenas de
suministro esa interrupción en el tram
porque podría comenzar precisamente este
viernes si las empresas ferroviarias no
llegan a un acuerdo sobre un nuevo
contrato con dos sindicatos los
sindicatos representan a unos 57 mil
trabajadores entre conductores e
ingenieros esto quieren incluir
cláusulas que les permitan ir al médico
o responder a emergencias familiares sin
ser penalizados el viernes se cumple el
periodo por ley y los empleados podrían
declararse en huelga o las empresas
podrían decretar un paro forzoso
cerrando sus instalaciones la
interrupción del servicio tendría un
impacto negativo en la cadena de
suministros y crearía una reacción en
cadena para el resto de la economía
estadounidense actualmente el presidente
de joe biden intenta mediar entre las
compañías y sindicatos para que lleguen
a un acuerdo antes del viernes bueno
hablamos ahora de américa latina porque
el presidente de méxico andrés manuel
lópez obrador negó que haga un castigo
de parte de eeuu en política energética
éstos tras la visita de los secretarios
estadounidenses el estado anthony
blinken y de comercio gina raimundo el
mandatario afirmó que ni siquiera se usó
la palabra
o sanción durante la reunión con blind
king y raimundo cuando estuvieron en
méxico para encabezar el diálogo
económico de alto nivel la política
energética mexicana es acusada de
favorecer a las empresas del estado en
perjuicio de la inversión extranjera lo
que sí anunciaron tras el acuerdo fue el
desarrollo en conjunto de chips o
semiconductores la fabricación de autos
eléctricos y una zona de energías
limpias en sonora estado fronterizo con
arizona jorge continúa la novela
alrededor de twitter y long moscas
porque los accionistas de esta compañía
están pidiendo la mosca que cumpla su
acuerdo de compra este martes los
accionistas de hecho votaron a favor del
acuerdo de adquisición de moss por 44
mil millones de dólares a un valor de
54,20 dólares por acción hay que tomar
en cuenta que las acciones de la
compañía se encuentran en 41 dólares por
acción casi en 25% por debajo del precio
acordado la votación se da días después
de que moss enviara su tercera carta a
twitter para rescindir de este acuerdo
en este caso por una supuesta
indemnización de 7 millones de dólares
que la empresa a su antiguo jefe de
seguridad peiter zatko que
posteriormente denunció supuestas
vulnerabilidades en materia de seguridad
y privacidad
simmons pierde la batalla judicial
tendría que adquirir twitter a través de
una fusión forzada por los tribunales
allí en delaware el tribunal dictaminó
que moss podría introducir los reclamos
exacto en su contrademanda contra la red
social jorge a usted gracias por esta
ampliación económica que dice con
nosotros que ya vamos a directo a
[Música]